so chess is a war it's a battle this is
our field each army gets the same amount
of pieces so it's a very fair one how do
we win wars we get more units more
material
the pieces are valued and how they are
valued that was excellent that you
mentioned it not randomly right you know
you go to hell
I don't know why this example you might
want it a movie theater popcorn cost
four dollars another one five why cuz
that's how they are in the mood no the
pieces in chess are based on real value
based on what they can do a rook is more
effective than a bishop why is it more
effective if you remember that's correct
but let's see yes exactly the bishop is
limited basically what you said just
eliminate two squirrels on its own color
the rule can go dark square light
squirrels we even gave maybe the best
example that at least I can think of a
queen queen is nine to ten points Luke
five Bishop three why would the Queen be
more than a working a bishop yes
but Luke 5c it's always easy when it's
under 10 Luke 5 Bishop 3:8 how come why
Queen will be 9 to 10 why would it Quinn
be more than a broken a bishop well how
it can go two more squares but look wait
let's show this one okay this is our
this is our super cool queen okay it's a
working a bishop right so this one might
I I always like to save my kid he
doesn't like to us but it's actually
really they would be very good in chess
but people first computer games but I
wouldn't blame him if they were
completely against when I was younger
probably be playing them also but he
wants to have a piece a queen and a
knight that's actually super cool then
you can do everything in one one thing
but this is our queen if you can go on
diagonals can go on straight lines
why DS look at that I did I'm not saying
it's easy why this is gonna be less oh
that's a tricky one less than this one
it's going to be less why 5 + 3 8 9 - 10
I know you will give me the right answer
yes
because this root can go whatever you
want but this be shop uh uh this Bishop
is stuck on dark color right the Queen
can be here in here so eight between
eight to eleven that's what we have our
Queen very very much pretty much
mathematically proven right is very
simple with a queen is better than a
look and a bishop but somewhat left then
I look into bishops so this is a perfect
example of the value of our pieces
alrighty we spoke about night we seen
some examples of checkmate we haven't
spoken much about stalemate and well we
will see maybe we'll discuss it today
what is tell me you know what first what
is checkmate
what is checkmate exactly yes you said
some things that were right
but you didn't say everything so the
king is not I would say instead of trap
being under attack meaning is under a
check you cannot move anywhere that's
correct you win the game depends we need
two other things to happen for this to
be a checkmate yes
that's stretching or raising your hand
to stretching oh man we need we need to
have like five minutes stretching after
the class like seriously yes I forgot I
forgot the question also all right today
we said check we said the King cannot
move but we need two other things to
happen yes ah that's what I need I need
three things to happen right three
things King one check the King another
check then cannot move cannot block and
not capture that's checkmate
what is stalemate quickly
yes what is tell me it's basically if if
to say pretty much no it's pretty much
that's that's what's happening but
really it is the king
there is no not just the king there is
no legal move that can be played in the
game there is no legal move that can be
played which means there can be only a
king this is actually the most common
one but there can be also many other
pieces and there will be no legal moves
that can be played for example let's
just quickly show something on the board
okay so we have this position so quickly
why does actually two two moves to
checkmate you
yes that is one Queen to e7 I'll just
put it here
checkmate all right number two very good
because it's a bit less simple and
ethically Queen g8 right did those two
squares are under control by the king
the Queen controlling dough squares and
also disco beautiful
now what about stalemate can you play a
move for white that will tell it and the
result in a stalemate is draw don't ask
me why doesn't make sense but that's the
result yes why - perfect
that was your move perfect because if we
play Queen to f6 whereas black king
gonna go now that's a draw
stalemate no we're now one important tip
you see in many many kids games you know
pretty much kids right that one player
gets to be with gigantic
advantage and the easiest way to avoid
stalemate is to keep checking if you
have like Queen and Luke and some other
pieces if you check all the time there
can be no stalemate this is one idea or
just to keep you eyes really really well
open and not have this but what happened
if there were many other pieces on the
board let me put the following position
white played this move without move and
here is my question which move can black
play right now yes
yes nothing
so it's also stalemate right how show me
which legal move legal means you can do
whatever you want you can give your
queen you can give you what you can do
anything but you cannot allow the
opponent to capture your king so
basically you play any move that you
want with black that doesn't allow his
King to be captured if you can do it
it's not a stalemate
so let's see can this bishop moves
anywhere because it it can it cannot
move according to the rules why because
the king will be kept with king will be
captured so the bishop is pinned what
about this knife can this knife move
anyone why not its pinned by which piece
if we add one tiny pawn for black the
pawn can move right by the way there are
two squares that we can head a pawn and
it will be a stalemate who wants to come
and put this on the boat two squares
they actually only want incredible only
one square that we can add this pawn and
it will be a stalemate which square is
that which one only ones who are black
to plan it is a stalemate
like black still has no mood to play
here you know for this for a second I
was saying ah also here there is no move
to play but YY which move can black play
here
well no it's - but which move King
perfect King f8 so only be six would be
alright so we understand stalemate right
it's not about can the King move or not
there can be position that the King
cannot move at all but there are many
other pieces that can move so stalemate
is almost like checkmate but with also
including other pieces so it is the king
is not under check that's correct and
there is no other legal move to be
played in that position
perfect then we were looking at captures
right we said we were looking a lot that
captures what did we say about captures
right
so when we have captures we want to
first start looking at their high-value
captures they're not necessarily going
to be the best one but we have to start
looking at them first
yes I was going to put exactly the same
position again excellent what's your
name
Mackenzie that was perfect I was going
to put it exactly same position of
similar as an example that you basically
match very similar what we see it's not
just the capture it is what we want to
capture now let's do something quickly
in our head if you have a possibility to
capture a walk but you have to give a
bishop you capture a book and you give a
bishop or you have a possibility to win
a night for free which one would you
prefer
yes Knight for free how many points you
win for a knight for free three and they
look for a bishop how many points - five
- three I told you as long as it's under
ten it's very easy to do right exactly
exactly so we do not care about how much
we capture we care about or how many
pieces what do we care about we care
about one word the difference the value
but the difference that's what we care
if I give 10 and I take 12 I want to
it's better than whatever sequence that
you want that you just win one you will
say oh you give you a queen how could
you give you a queen well if you give
you a queen for two looks and a bishop
you won material much better than
winning a pawn
so it's always always people ask me many
well what do you think kid should start
learn how to play chess my my view is
whenever you can do basic math whenever
you really know you know I'm joking with
their fingers all the time but I just
emphasize how critical I think it is
whatever a kid can do 8 minus 6 equals 2
you can play chess that's it because
then you understands the value of the
pieces if you don't understand the value
of the pieces you are in the wrong game
because chess at the end at the bottom
and the middle is a material game that's
it
it's a material game no championship
matches yes as much as genius the
players are and they are really really
really genius like not not just saying
like those are people with IQ much
closer to 200 and less cuz Paulo Fisher
and many others much much much doesn't
matter at the end games are being
decided most of them by some more
material advantage usually not really
modern upon usually so this was our now
McKenzie do you remember a little bit
the position that was last week you
think if I would let you I'll give you
two minutes to go to the board and set
it up can you do it oh no no all right
so you do remember no you remember a lot
come on don't sell yourself short let's
see maybe you can help me that was
excellent
looking to Knights and there were three
ways to capture let's let's see if we
can together try and reconstruct our
position you remember where was the
piece that we could have captured on wit
square which one you remember I'm
telling you we we will do it all right
let's see because by the way one of the
qualities that we as chess players want
or should have is what memory I mean you
are not gonna believe just as some of
them what they can remember what did we
say here yes
mm-hmm and which piece is the best Oh
like to take either one of the night
right because if we will take with the
night we have left three points we are
equal right we take a bishop last bishop
give a knight for it so now it's equal
then we take so at the end of the day
this is what we need to know basic math
we take bishop a knight we give a knight
we study tiny equations we say night
night go from its side view in a bishop
and if we take with the roof it's not
exactly this way right because we will
take a bishop and a knight but we will
give I work five points oh wait so that
was really what we did and it's
excellent that we remember now the
question is are those topics those
topics are they only important for
captions or for many other decisions
that we might take during the game many
other decisions I think so too
this is you know well let's start with
one or two simple positions let's look
at this position this is the position
and it is why to play what should I play
why to play capture right with it but
all it's always easy to say capture so
we really know the pawn capture the
Queen on c5 getting out of check in that
way now let's see let's say that this
was the position I just change it tiny
bit I'm changing it here and I'm
changing it now to white to play what
should I play here
why does in check here whites the play
is in check oh okay look to be sick so I
remember it we will see that which other
moose yes Queen to this okay so we have
would be six Queen to default any other
suggestions ideas I can move the king
somewhere but we're in somewhere very
somewhere somewhere can we move the King
we cannot hold the king
all right I agree we cannot move the
king but there is one other move there
is one other move available for White
Queen work mystics was suggested 24 was
suggested what else okay why is it white
you're right why is it the worst move
that's perfect
and perfect and what do you think about
will be six right and so the best move
that you will play is gonna be also also
me so you see it's not that our
immediate decision are always about
captures even a decision how to block it
check has to rely on on the captures on
what can be captured and what not
we're dreaming fear that were suggested
world Mystics was the first mood it was
suggested it all be six blocking the
check is it a good move
why no
for free queen III you mentioned before
light is the worst move because not only
it loses the Queen more importantly it
gets it gets checkmated Queen III get
shake matron so the best move and again
the best move because we can play this
way is to play let's put it here is to
play Queen to d4 and in order to see
Queen before I just remember one thing
that I did forget to mention that we
spoke before because I was asking you a
question remember I question that I was
a senior I was asking you what is as
long as it's what are your safe I was
asking you what is it more important to
see our moves our threats or our
opponent more than our opponent threats
if we remember both we made the huge
step to become chess players because
then we are thinking about the entire
board so why is it critical because if
we say oh man I'm going to go to d4 and
it's going to take it then we're toast
we cannot play but if we say mmm I'll
block he's gonna take and I'm gonna take
so we thought about our look let's see
how many steps we thought we thought
about our move our opponent move and
then again one of the differences
between chess players is how deep can
they analyze and then it's some level
how deep are accurate how fast so on so
on so on and so on but it no one in the
world doesn't matter if you are an
underworld champion Carlos and the best
player in the world or just one of you
sitting here we will our thinking
process has to be the same I move my
opponent move well then let's see how
far we can see okay
the next example is one of the best one
that I like so I'm going to put it on
the board and you're going to think very
well by the way one of the
books that I recommend for you kids to
study form and in some of those examples
are taken from is a book by Susan Polgar
which was women world champion and
actually little friend of mine we know
one another for well for a long long
years and she's just a great great not
just chest loved by an author and she is
actually teaching not far away from here
in Webster University one of the best
may be debased college team she would
excellent books for kids and one of them
the one that I'm using now is a world
champions guide to chest one another
book for maybe a little bit more
advanced levels is my world
chest so it's chess tactics for
champions at least this book I would
strongly strongly suggest if you will go
after it and watch this video online so
a world champion guy to chess I think is
one of the most perfect books that I
would recommend every young kid to start
doing some chest oh wait
so let's put our beautiful position and
we're gonna thank you and we're gonna
thank you it is why to play white as to
possibilities to play here whenever you
have two possibilities and not extremely
clear ones this is something a bit more
demanding how should white play I will
just say this if someone he's telling me
what should white play and I want him to
tell me why not to play the other move
you're certain you can do both all right
what should I play
that is perfect
that is perfect you see that how a chess
player would think it's not that I say
mmm that looks good because you know
what is if you see a good move what you
should be doing running to plate as
quickly as possible or maybe you have a
better one
right so the fact that you see I moved
between the pond
you know I I've seen many many games
someone say hey when a pond excellent
but what if the other move you could
have worn a bishop
yeah a queen or something much more so
relatively the move that you've played
is bad right so in this position it's
actually very clear right King h5 like
you mentioned is absolutely the worst
move checkmate
game over so our only move is going to
be exactly Bishop capture King capture
and write it up to font and supposed to
win this game if you will play next
example is also one of my favorite I'll
give you my favorite same idea one
player is under check what is our best
way to get out of check
that was annoying super complaining I
need to give black another bishop robbed
a nice alrighty
why just to play
yes
but but you want to take the night right
that's a good idea actually actually
let's actually that's a decent move but
wait why does too much much much better
moves if white could played it let's say
pathetically Detroit can play in ignore
his opponent there's a better they are
better moves than taking the night which
would be a better move than taking the
night clean capture Bishop I've kept
your bad I'll capture back I'll catch
your back no you want to capture the
pawn will capture back want to give me a
queen for a bishop
yes and what would cream g7 be excellent
but wait and there is another way for
white to play checkmate yes okay so
Queen g7 is checkmate Queenie charity's
checkmate and another move that was
suggested okay this win tonight now we
have a tiny problem what is our problem
we cannot play Queen g7 and why can't we
play Queen G servant we are in check
incredible right
incredible we are in so can you take the
rule
we can move show me where I can move
tell me you some well I need to find out
well is this somewhere that I can always
move and I can't see the squirrels King
III we after the club's going to speak
about this dimension that we have there
you cannot it come closer
no oh man now you're joining a large
group of people that say that I'm
intimidating alright so what should we
play yes I know do we say that yes c4
white is two who will get why would I be
now white is winning after c4 so first
of all you know let's make big you know
one of the great things about chess now
seriously for let's take one minute one
minute break from chess and think about
what we can use from chess to real life
seriously what are we really doing here
we are solving problems solving problems
that's what we really do here the
problem you say oh how am I gonna beat
an ant well that's it that's a difficult
one right maybe there are one or two
players in the world that thinking about
it
Magnus Carlsen the best player in the
world maybe Kramnik that bit cuz foul it
is not our problem right that's
difficult but our problem right now we
have a simple one how we get out of
check and one of the greatest thing
about chess is that you take a very very
very complicated situation and the way
to solve those things you have to start
breaking them into small problems you
know you say how am I going to play this
position okay
that's a huge big question but the first
question you have is a simple one how do
I get out of check how do I get out of
check there are only two ways to play
quint egg is going to give you a queen
for Bishop c4 unless there is something
horrible with that is almost a necessary
move that way of thinking is much bigger
than chess it will for chess players it
will help you in life in thinking about
in school in thinking about everything
that you want if you think correctly
when you will right now in few years
going to start having math problems in
school and you will say ok so this is
the question that I have and now I don't
know let's say I don't know if any of
you you are probably doing it ok a
college which you know point a driving
20 miles there another tell from point B
driving here driving there you know what
is the total distance they drove when
they met at this point have you done
those yeah it done so if you will think
about it
exactly in the process of chess I'm
telling you it will make it much much
easier for you I mean those things are
ridiculously simple all those things if
you have the right approach ok so this
is what I need to understand and those
are the fact that I have in front of me
and this is my way of figuring this out
very easy if we think in the right way
the same here well we are in check and
we have only 2 ways to stop it
Quinn take is usually a very bad move
usually if you have to give you a queen
for a bishop either you have checkmate
or something extremely powerful to
follow or you are pretty much a toast
so after C for now let's see white stop
the check what is white threatening
white is threatening checkmate white is
threatening checkmate and somehow if
miraculously black managed to save them
probably f6 is only move then white
might be well the capture and at the end
the night is hanging and the knight
cannot easily move because the knight is
defending there
look so this this is what chest you know
statistically almost no one in this room
is going to be a grandmaster what to do
because you know I guess there was
amazed I thought it there a bit more
there are seven billion people in the
world and there are 1,400 grandmasters
so 1 out of 5 million that's amazing
1 out of 5 million now I think well
let's know but less alive Nobel Prize
winners but are many many other things
but what we can study is that process of
thinking let's do something else this
one is my favorite favorite one if you
can do this one's perfect then we maybe
did something all right now I have the
questions first question what is the
material balance here but exactly tell
me which side has how many points more
if you can and then and then not just
how many points but which pieces against
which pieces are the difference the
difference so first question which one
has more points and how many
Blackie's two O's
yeah infinity or 0 we which one the to
prefer yes
one more point
colas right before you just forgot a
book so instead of white being up three
black is up to because just three - five
five but how can we do it easily without
counting 20 if you're counting 20 you're
doing it in the hard way how do we do it
you know you see again simple math one
side of equation and other side you
don't need to add every part let's see
how we do it
Queen Queen do I need to count it
I don't need to count it I have a queen
you have a queen I only care about one
word they're different so if I have a
queen and you have the Queen out look
look do I need to count it no look
does white ever walk no so black has the
book we put in our head Knight does
black have any minor pieces no look
night now one two three four five one
two three four five so a simple answer
would be black is up to material points
walk verses and night the same way that
when you look at any digit any number
right you look 954 verses 854 okay four
five 900 take on it 100 more that's
exactly what we did now write that
that's why I wasn't joking when I said
when should we should stop playing chess
when we can do those in a reasonable way
is this so just how we that's why by the
way I started with with what I start I
started with the actually the high value
pieces cause it's making it easier I
don't want to start from the bottom
Wow I've just out with the top pieces Oh
excellent so black is up too much
he'll point and he's checking white not
only is checking white straightening
white screen so this is going to be our
last position today but what is white
gonna play oh well they I don't know
which movie Zoo but we'll wait for
another 1 minute okay because you know
after who usually comes up my guess I
think you're still gonna be flying over
here if I want like your answer so what
is your answer which one who you will
play that's a very good move that's the
best move and very nice in the book
there is whiter than other book so white
is actually up material so if white is
up material even playing the inferior
move Queen take Queen will give white
will leave white with more material but
I'm listening right exactly
this is why I put it in a situation that
if you don't play this if you don't play
this move that you suggested white will
be worse if white has a look you can
take and is still winning it will be up
tonight but in this situation white
really is one move to play to win or to
be better and it's exactly this walk III
yes of course the queen is under attack
the king is in check but if we play this
move we are pinning we are pinning black
screen if black had a piece to block he
would be doing well but he doesn't so
black is going to lose the rook for the
Queen this is for example you know maybe
with this we can just open a topic and
you know hopefully maybe we will get one
time to continue that off with others
pins this is a super important topics in
once we cleared away from checks and
captures those are the basic way our
most straightforward approaches then we
have many tactical ideas we will use
pins to win material folks skews
discovered attack double attack many
many many other ideas that make chess
tiny bit more complicated than just hey
I can capture your piece right if we if
that was everything then we would finish
now and we said as we know everything
about chess okay
so we've seen this example we've seen
more example about material we repeated
quite a lot the base and what we have
mentioned in our first examples those
pins and folks are another I would say
higher level of chess but if you did it
now and you did it excellent well that
means that that's where we should be
headed
you